sensitive i/o info in educational and a
practical interactive platform to learn
bioinformatics of all kinds of different
data first of all I'm going to show you
an area where you can see different
types of courses that we made so that
you can enjoy a full variety of systems
biology and machine learning for
bioinformatics on this platform these
courses you can view over here and see
the full curriculum that is provided for
free right now you can see under
curriculum and the different topics that
are being covered some of them include a
quiz a lot of them included lectures
with videos and you can preview some of
them as well as if you register you can
then take the course now alongside this
platform we also offer an actual
bioinformatics platform the bio
informatics platform covers many
different data types you can see
next-generation sequencing data mass
spec data structural biology data and
then a whole section dedicated to
integration and modeling including this
machine learning section now what you